now we're going to look at a very famous
algorithm called the gram schmidt
algorithm the name stands for two
mathematicians graham and schmidt
so we'll we'll take a look at it and
it's
it has to do with linear independence
and in fact it is
an algorithm i mean from for right now
its main purpose is to detect whether a
set
of vectors is linearly dependent or
linearly
independent we're actually going to see
later that it is enormously useful
in a lot of practical applications but
that's not going to come up for a while
so right now it is again i'm sorry just
kind of
weird and abstract i should also say
another thing about it
um you know we described one algorithm
already that's the k-means algorithm
and now we're going to describe graham
schmidt
i guess i'm not one who thinks that
students should be forced to implement
these things by themselves i mean
i don't know i mean i suppose there's a
point to it um
i don't uh but it will describe it and
then of course you know when you're
doing this uh
in practice uh you're gonna rely on
uh on on implementations written by
others
um so so the point of it is not that
you're gonna go out and code this
yourself
but the point is you should understand
what it is and how it works and what it
does
uh but when you actually use it you're
gonna call uh you know some
routine written by someone else okay
so here's what it is um for now we'll
see that it's a lot more than this but
for now here's what it is
it is simply an algorithm that checks if
a set of vectors is linearly independent
that's it um we're gonna see it has a
lot of other uses later in fact
uh you know in the whole class there's
about two or three algorithms and
this is they're basically all related to
that it's all it's all
this this one this is graham she man
okay
so here it is we're just gonna jump
right in um and like i said right now
it's kind of abstract but uh
that it'll you know it'll emerge later
in the book
uh that it has a lot of uses okay so
we're given
a set of vectors uh and they're n
vectors and we have k of them
and what it's going to do is it's going
to process them the vectors
one at a time um and in the end
it is going to uh will be we'll be able
to use this to determine if those
vectors
are linearly independent or linearly
dependent
right now to remind you linearly
dependent means that there's a linear
combination of them that's zero
with the coefficients not paul being
zero a linear independent means
that's not the case okay so here's what
it does um
the first step is it takes the eighth
vector ai
and it subtracts from a i
um a it may oh it maintains i should say
it maintains
a set of vectors uh q1 q2 q3
up to qk unless the algorithm terminates
early
it generates a set of q's which are
orthonormal
um oh i should mention uh that the
uh the notation uh q
uh is this is just a convention um
typically a set of queues are
orthonormal vectors right
by the way same um same for u's and v's
uh and
this is just conventions so okay but in
this case
it's following the convention so the
vectors
uh it's gonna generate a set of vectors
q one q two which are orthonormal so
here's what's gonna happen
um you're going to take a uh
a i and you are going to subtract from
it
the these uh this
the inner product of q1 and ai
well that's a number times q1 and so on
now what you'll recognize you may
remember this from
last time in fact is that if
if a i is a linear combination
of q1 up to qy minus one then in fact
all of this is equal to ai and qy tilde
is zero
so if q utility turns out to be zero
that mean
that means that a i is a linear
combination of q one up to q
uh a minus one q sub i minus one sorry
um now what we do is again we check if q
y tilde is zero
if it is we quit uh and because
in that case it'll turn out that these
vectors are linearly dependent
if not if it's non-zero we simply divide
by the norm and we normalize and we get
q
i from q y tilde okay so
if this algorithm runs all the way to
the end and does not quit
as in step two here of the algorithm
then that's going to be that's going to
tell us that those vectors are linearly
independent
um if it stops hurt if it stops an
algorithm in
in step j then it's going to tell us
that the
vector aj is actually a linear
combination of the previous ones a1 up
to aj minus 1.
and that means that our set of vectors
is linearly dependent
okay so that's the algorithm now the one
that's actually used numerically in
practice
is mathematically equivalent but it's
not quite the same as this
i mean it generates exactly the same
vectors and things like that but
it's slightly different okay now let's
walk through an example
here's two vectors which are two two
vectors um
they're a one and a two um this gray
circle is showing you all points of norm
one
so it's a circle basically of of radius
um okay and so let's see so that would
tell us for example the norm of a1 is
about one point
whatever three i'm making that up but
that's about it okay
so let's run gram schmidt well we grab
a1
and the first thing we do is we subtract
off from a1
some linear combination of the previous
cues but we have no previous q so we
subtract nothing
and so that tells us that q1 this is the
first step
right q1
there we go sorry about that so q1 tilde
is in fact just nothing but a1
okay so now that's the first step we
check if it's zero
it is definitely not zero and so we
normalize it and that means we shrink it
to get q1 and you see now it's green
and you can see that it's it's arrow the
tip of the arrow
you know shows is on that unit circle
it's what it's called
and that means it now has norm one so
that that's q1
okay next step now it gets interesting
right because now we go over to here
and what happens is we take a2 and we
subtract
off from a2 a multiple of q1
to make the result orthogonal to q1 and
so
the correct thing to to subtract is
minus q1 transpose a2 q1 and that's this
vector here
and we end up with this red vector here
which is q2 tilde now notice that q2
tilde
is orthogonal to q1 because that's
actually what we're doing is we're
we're we're slowly producing and we're
generating a set of orthonormal vectors
okay now at this point
it's they're just ortho they're not
normal yet and so what we do here is we
check if q
tilde is zero it is not zero and
therefore we
we scale it to make it have length one
and we end up with
there we go there's q one and q two and
so uh this is extremely boring
uh there's no reason to have any
interest in because
there's nothing we just to be completely
open about it
there's nothing practical we can do with
this yes so yeah so i'm just i'm admit
that's all
i'm inventing it okay so uh so the point
is if you run the
the if you run gram schmidt on these two
vectors a1 and a2
that's what comes out q1 and q2 and
you could well ask who cares and
i would say you don't know the answers
you don't know yet
you'll know later that this actually can
do all sorts of super cool practical
stuff but for the moment
this is all just weird and abstract
whatever so just trust me
all right so we can
analyze this a bit i'm not going to go
into it in too much detail
because this is the kind of thing that's
best done by you kind of you know
reading through the book carefully and
stuff like that
but i will say just a few things about
how the algorithm what it does
so the first thing and i think our
example already kind of gave us hint
is the cues that come out of the gram
schmidt algorithm are orthonormal
okay and the the reason we can check um
suppose it's true for i minus one and
we'll show this by uh recursion
okay in that orthogonalization step you
are actually subtracting
exactly the coefficient you need to of
the previous cues
to make it orthogonal uh to all of them
okay so when you finish qy tilde is
orthogonal to all the previous ones that
that's how that works
now to see that all we do is we take an
inner product
with qj so qj transpose q
i tilde is equal to and this is qy tilde
here
and i'm just going to simply work it out
and see what we get
but over here we get things like q
j tilde q 1 well
that is going to be that's going to be
0 right so the only one that comes out
is we end up with q
j transpose uh sorry the inner product
of q j and a i
and then again q j and a i and just
subtracting to get zero so it's
orthogonal
um and what that says is that the new
it says q tilde is orthogonal to all the
previous ones
but if i scale it by a number because to
make its norm one it's still orthogonal
so
so the so the q's are orthogonal and of
course
the normalization step guarantees that
the norm is one
okay so so it says that the qis that
come out of the back end
of the gram-schmidt algorithm are
orthonormal
okay now if it hasn't turned if the
algorithm has not terminated
before iteration i then it turns out a
i is a linear combination of q1 through
qy
and we can even see that because we can
actually very explicitly write down what
the linear combination is
it is literally the norm of q y tilde
times q y
plus and then again this inner product
uh
these are inner product coefficients
it's the one you've already seen before
in an orthonormal
basis expansion so what we do
is we we get that that's very explicit
so a i
is literally a linear combination of q
one up to
q i okay uh in fact
well that's one of the ways we could say
it is that each each a i
is a linear combination of q1
up to q i okay
and it turns out that reverse is true
too each qi is a linear combination of
a1 through ai
and again you can see that by induction
i'm not going to go into the details
there
but that's that's not that that's the
case
okay we get to uh early termination
um if it terminates in step j what that
says
is that q j tilde
is equal to zero that means that when
you took a i
and you aj and when you subtracted the
appropriate linear combination of q one
up to q j minus one from it you got zero
and that tells you actually that that
equality holds
now now we'll now we'll notice that each
of these qys here
is a linear combination of the ais
a1 up to aj minus 1. so this is a linear
combination of linear combinations
linear combination of linear combination
is again a linear combination
and that says that when it stops it says
that aj
is a linear combination of a1 up to aj
minus 1.
that's that is one of the definitions of
being dependent
so what that says is that the the gram
schmidt
algorithm if it terminates early then it
it term it terminates because the a's
you started with were linearly dependent
i want to say a little bit about the
complexity of the gram schmidt algorithm
about how long does it take to you know
basically how many flops does it take to
actually carry this out
well let's figure it out in iteration i
uh
you have you have to evaluate i minus
one inner products right
um and that costs each inner product
costs
two n minus one flocks uh and
there's i minus one so that's that okay
so that's the total number of flops
to compute q itilly you have to
subtract subtract off various things and
that costs you 2 and
i minus 1 flops okay
um then it costs you
three n flops uh to
calculate the norm and then divide q
tilde by that norm to get q
i so that's three n flops and the total
is now
uh we add this plus this
plus that and we have to now sum that
from i
equals 1 to k and you get something
horrible that looks like that
now you could work out what that is in
fact it's exactly this and i
i'll i'll tell you why it's i'm going to
use a formula which you can just
remember
or look up or go to wikipedia to find
out or something like that
and it's this it's the sum from i equals
1 to k of i minus 1
is actually k times k minus 1 over 2. in
other words
the following sum you know if you can
check it if k
equals 5 and this says you should add up
0 plus 1 plus 2 plus 3 plus 4
and you will find out that that is 5
times 4 divided by 2 which is 10.
and it's correct i mean maybe i misspoke
it but
it's correct so anyway so you get some
horrible thing like this now what you
have to remember about
flop counts is it's extremely crude
so we're going to drop what are what we
call
non-dominant terms right so for example
uh you know when you work this out the
biggest term you're possibly going to
get is going to be this 4n
times the k squared divided by 2 that's
2n k squared
all the other terms have a coefficient
of either n or k which is smaller
and we're interested in the case when n
and k are reasonably large
so we just dropped them and so this is
completely centered in a flop count and
you would say that
graham schmidt has a complexity
of two nk squared flops um and the truth
is this
it's not quite right um but the whole
flop count
model is so approximate that this is
just fine
right because we're you know we're
pretending that multiplies and adds and
divisions and things like that
even a square root because we have to
calculate a norm and we're kind of
pretending that these
all cost the same which they don't okay
so you get 2 nk squared
that's interesting right because it
tells you that it is um
it is it is quadratic in
the number of vectors that you apply it
to
and it's linear you would say in the
dimension
n